.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
* Bluesige Bassmusik *
Jede Stadt, die etwas auf sich hält,
hat irgendwo auf ihrer Schattenseite
eine Strasse,
wo all das seinen Platz findet,
was an der schönen Seepromenade
unerwünscht ist.
In Luzern war das schon immer
die Baselstrasse.
Wer hier zu Hause ist, steht nicht
im Rampenlicht der Gesellschaft,
sondern führt - wie die Strasse
selbst - eher ein Schattendasein.
* Strassenlärm *
* Hundebellen, Schreie *
* Unverständliche, laute Rufe *
* Donnergrollen *
(Mann) Ein Lastwagen kommt
und reisst den Balkon ein.
Ich rufe zurück. Ist gut?
* Bohrlärm *
Der Alltag in der Baselstrasse ist
für den Künstler Christoph Fischer
die Quelle seiner Inspiration.
* Hupen,
unverständliche Schimpftirade *
Fuck you!
Der Asphalt vor seinem Atelier
ist für ihn die Bühne,
auf welcher der Zufall täglich
ein neues Theaterstück inszeniert.
Das ist eben er.
Einer der Hauptdarsteller
in diesem Theater
ist der pensionierte Strassenarbeiter
Heinz Gilli.
Jeden Tag pünktlich um 18 Uhr
betritt er die Bühne,
immer dann, wenn die neue
Gratiszeitung am Kiosk erscheint.
Man stellt sich ihn auf dem Kreisel
vor, wie das aussieht.
Heinz hat Christoph
zu einem neuen Projekt inspiriert.
Auf dem Kreuzstutz
soll ein Kreiselkunstwerk entstehen.
So soll das wirken.
Ich vergass, etwas zu sagen.
Meintest du den Abgang zum Geiser?
Hier wäre ich sehr froh,
wenn du aufräumen könntest.
Tschau.
Wenn man bedenkt:
70 Nationen und 70 % Ausländer.
Da muss man froh sein,
wie es zuletzt zu und her ging.
Schau hier, die schwarzen Bananen!
Viele kommen mit Reklamationen
zu mir.
Er würde alte,
schwarze Bananen verkaufen.
Aber die Leute kennen die
Gemüsebananen nicht, die sind so.
In der Baselstrasse
trifft man einiges an.
Die Nacht in der Baselstrasse
hat ihre Spuren hinterlassen.
Sie zu beseitigen,
ist für den Hausbesitzer
Pete Schaeren
immer wieder eine mühsame Pflicht.
Manchmal findet man eine Adresse.
V.a. wenn Abfallsäcke hier liegen.
Aber in diesem Fall sind es
nur Möbel, da findet man nichts.
Es steht auf meinem Grundstück.
Ich bin verantwortlich.
Ja, leider.
Entschuldigung.
* Staubsauger *
Ja?
Weisst du, wer die Holzsachen
draussen hinstellte?
Ich weiss es nicht.
Weisst du, wer das Holz
beim Haus hingestellt hat?
Ich muss es wegräumen, weil ...
Sonst bekomme ich eine Busse.
- Ja, das stimmt.
Die Polizei ist da sehr streng.
Kebab, Pommes frites, Burger.
Pouletschnitzel mit Pommes frites.
Ja.
Ähm, Beef? Beef or no?
What's in ...
- Kebab?
Kebab. Ah, Shawarma.
In Arabish Shawarma.
Okay.
- Kebab.
Für Amal Naser aus Syrien ist die
Baselstrasse ein Ort der Hoffnung.
Sie hat soeben
einen positiven Asylbescheid bekommen
und will sich
eine neue Existenz aufbauen.
Keine lernen ... Ich arbeite ...
Training in ... Syria.
- Aha.
Translate, okay?
Ich lese, ich komme ... Sentence.
Ähm ... Satz.
- Satz.
Du machst einen ganzen Satz.
Wie heisst ... Wie heisst du?
Okay?
- Ich heisse Romy. Wie heisst du?
Ich heisse Amal.
Vor 20 Jahren hat Pete
das Haus mit der Nummer 58 gekauft
und mit viel Eigenarbeit renoviert.
170 Jahre hat das Gemäuer
bereits auf dem Buckel.
Heute beherbergt es eine bunte
Mischung von Mietern aus aller Welt.
Kann ich das reinbringen?
- Ja.
Okay.
Das ist für diese ...
Das ist ein Kochfeld.
Weil die obere kaputt ist, defekt.
- Okay.
Ich muss es auswechseln,
aber sie sind nicht zu Hause.
Okay.
Darf ich das
hier irgendwo deponieren?
Bitte?
- Darf ich das deponieren?
Nein.
- Weisst du, nur hinstellen.
Ja, komm!
- Das heisst deponieren.
Auf Deutsch.
- Aha.
Nein, das glaube ich nicht!
Ich kaufte extra so viele Plektrums.
So viele.
Auch der Schweizer Strassenmusiker
Daniele Martin
hat im Haus von Pete
eine Bleibe gefunden.
Alle Plektrums sind fort,
das glaube ich nicht.
Aber ja,
das ist jetzt wirklich lästig.
Darum mag ich es
gar nicht unbedingt -
auch wenn es gut gemeint ist -
wenn ab und zu
jemand für mich aufräumt.
Denn genau so kommt es heraus.
Gab es keine Probleme mehr
mit Kakerlaken?
Nein.
- Mit den Käfern. Keine Probleme?
Die grosse ...
Ich brachte einmal grosse Köder.
Die waren sehr wirkungsvoll
gegen Kakerlaken, glaube ich.
Oh ja.
- Ja.
Okay.
Ja, gut.
Dann komme ich wieder
und hole das ab.
Das ist
für die tibetische Familie oben.
Ist das gut? Okay.
# Ja, das isch d'Schwiz,
gib mer dini Hand.
dis Land, mis Land.
# Ja, das isch d'Schwiz,
gib mer dini Hand.
dis Land, mis Land.
Soll ich spielen? Ich würde es
sehr gerne gleich spielen.
# Inzwüsche bini 36,
han vill erläbt und nachedänkt.
Inzwischen bin ich 40,
aber das klingt einfach besser.
# Und brüele vor mich hi,
will flueche längscht nüt meh nützt.
Es klingt nicht gut, 40 Jahre alt.
# Ich ha i de letschte füf Jahr
eso vill gschafft, ich han Familie.
# Und min neue Bueb ...
# ... und ich.
# Wänn mir eus gsehnd,
isch das e Freud.
Weil das Original
nicht mehr zutrifft.
# Das isch mini Schwiz,
mis Fläckli heili Wält.
Trifft leider auch nicht mehr zu.
# Ja, das isch mini Schwiz.
Entschuldigung.
# Das isch mini Schwiz,
mis Fläckli heili Wält.
Wieso ist sie nicht mehr heile Welt?
Ähm, meine Ex und ich
haben in den ersten drei Monaten
zusammengespannt.
Er hatte die sog. Dreimonatskoliken,
gleichzeitig Laktoseintoleranz.
Immer, wenn er weinte und schrie,
mussten wir
das ganze Programm durchprobieren,
warum er weint:
Wickeln, ähm ... Milch ...
Was war noch? Schlafen.
Er weinte immer.
* Melancholische Bassklänge *
* Radiosprecher im Hintergrund *
Eben, manchmal passiert etwas
und manchmal ...
... passiert nichts.
Ich stehe nicht ständig hier
und schaue, was ich aufnehmen kann.
Ich arbeite meistens hier
und habe es im Blickwinkel,
wenn sich
etwas Ungewöhnliches bewegt.
Das nehme ich dann wahr
und springe auf.
Mit dem geplanten Kreiselkunstwerk
betritt der Illustrator und Zeichner
Christoph künstlerisches Neuland.
Bildhauerei
ist eigentlich nicht sein Fachgebiet.
Er ist mir eigentlich
bereits vor zehn Jahren aufgefallen,
seit ich hier bin.
Früher war er
Strassenwischer dieses Quartiers.
Er hatte jeweils frühmorgens
den Schneepflug angemacht,
wodurch ich aufgewacht bin.
* Gedämpfter Motorenlärm *
Die Strassenschlucht
am Rande der Stadt Luzern
hat schon viele Immigrationswellen
aufgefangen.
Der Volksmund hat ihr -
je nach politischer Weltlage -
immer wieder andere Namen gegeben.
In den 60er-Jahren
nannte man sie Little Italy,
später hiess sie Neu Belgrad oder man
bezeichnete sie gar als das Getto.
Für viele Luzerner aber
war die Baselstrasse
einfach nur die Rue de Blamage.
Ha ha, Problem ja.
Haben Sie alles?
- Ich suche eine ... Wohnung.
In der Baselstrasse.
- In der Baselstrasse?
Das ist sehr schwierig.
Es ist sehr schwierig.
Amals grösster Wunsch ist es,
ihre durch den syrischen Bürgerkrieg
auseinandergerissene Familie
wieder zusammenzuführen.
Ihren Mann Adnan hat die Flucht
aus Syrien nach Prag verschlagen,
ihre einzige Tochter Angela
musste sie in Damaskus zurücklassen.
... now. Skype.
And meine Tochter in Syria.
Or no?
- Ah, ähm, ja.
Hast du einen PC hier? Einen Laptop?
Kannst du Skype öffnen
und mit mir reden?
(Frau) Ja, kann ich,
aber bald wird der Strom abgestellt.
Dann machen wir ganz schnell,
solange wir noch Strom haben.
Angela,
ich kann an nichts anderes denken,
als dass du endlich hier bist.
Ich möchte nicht,
dass du dir Sorgen machst.
Es ist unsere Schuld.
Du hast dir dein Leben
nicht so ausgesucht,
sei es in Syrien oder in Europa.
Wir haben dich dazu gezwungen.
Aber wir hatten keine Wahl,
wir mussten unsere Heimat verlassen.
Wieso verurteilen sie uns
als Terroristen?
Wir haben uns bloss
für die Vernunft eingesetzt.
Unser einziger Fehler war, dass wir
unsere Meinung frei äussern wollten.
Wir müssen deine Flucht so planen
wie meine.
Du musst dieselbe Route nehmen
wie ich.
Mir ist wichtig,
dass du sicher ankommst.
Angela, ich denke an nichts anderes,
als dass du endlich bei mir bist.
Als der Bürgerkrieg in den Strassen
am Rande von Damaskus wütete,
richtete Amal zusammen mit ihrem Mann
eine Krankenstation ein,
um Verletzte zu versorgen.
Sie wurde mehrmals verhaftet
und ihre Tochter drängte darauf,
dass ihre Eltern das Land verlassen.
Die Universitäten in Damaskus
sind zwar offen.
Aber da sind immer wieder
Checkpoints -
und bei jedem kann man verhaftet
oder gedemütigt werden.
Wenn meine Tochter
von der Uni nach Hause kam,
hatte sie jedes Mal Angst,
dass wir weg sind -
und dass sie uns
nie mehr wiedersehen würde.
Als wir dann
aus dem Gefängnis kamen,
hat sie uns angefleht,
das Land zu verlassen.
Sie hielt die ständige Angst um uns
nicht mehr aus.
Ohne Visum konnten wir
unsere Tochter nicht mitnehmen.
Im Libanon wollten wir sie
nicht bleiben lassen,
also liessen wir sie
in Syrien zurück und beschlossen,
es später zu versuchen.
Die Überraschung war,
dass die Schweiz
keine Familienzusammenführung
machen wollte,
weil meine Tochter
schon volljährig ist.
Jetzt versuchen wir,
über das Rote Kreuz
ein Visum für sie zu bekommen,
damit wir endlich wieder
zusammen sind.
* Melancholische Bassklänge *
Das hat niemand geglaubt, oder.
Dass ich es noch einmal
packen würde
nach 17 Jahren an der Nadel.
Ich war doch
fünfeinhalb Jahre sauber.
Das ist nicht nichts.
In dieser Zeit
gründete ich eine Familie.
Das Kind habe ich nicht verloren.
Wenn wir zusammen sind ...
... dann ...
... scheisst es ihn an,
wenn ich nur schon aufs WC gehe.
Geschweige denn eine Zigarette
auf dem Balkon rauche -
das wird bereits
ein schwieriges Unterfangen.
Es scheisst ihn an und er sagt:
"Oh, Papa, geh nicht rauchen,
spiel mit mir!"
Ja.
Ja, das ist mein Stolz.
Jetzt ist er vier.
Hier lernte er erst gerade laufen.
* Klopfen *
Arrivo!
* Kirchenglocke *
Ja, da ist Christoph vom Kreuzstutz.
Vom Kreisel gegenüber.
Christoph Fischer.
Wir haben letzte Woche
zusammen geredet.
Aha? Super. Perfekt. Ja.
Dann kommst du bald?
Ja? Super.
Ich freue mich, bis dann.
Bis dann, tschau, Heinz. Merci.
Es war für Christoph nicht leicht,
sich zu überwinden
und Heinz anzurufen,
denn eine Absage von Heinz
hätte seine ganze Vorarbeit
infrage gestellt.
Damit du informiert bist,
was das Ganze gibt.
Im Kreisel soll es eine Ebene geben.
Die Figur wird etwa 3 m hoch.
Das ist die Idee.
Wenn der Wind kommt,
fällt er nicht um.
Nein.
* Er lacht. *
Die Baubewilligung
ist noch ein Detail.
Die brauchst du dafür?
- Ja, sicher.
Du, alles. Ich habe mehr
als ein halbes Jahr gewartet.
Vielleicht mal so,
wie du es bei ihm siehst.
Halte es mal so!
Nach hinten. Genau so.
Am Boden?
- Vielleicht am Boden.
Oder so, wie du ihn halten magst.
Ja, sehr schön.
* Melancholische Bassklänge *
Was hast du gedacht,
als dich Christoph
zum ersten Mal
für dieses Projekt anfragte?
Ich dachte, die Idee sei gut.
Darum sagte ich auch Ja.
Doch, doch.
Ich meine, er hätte ja auch
jemand anders aussuchen können.
Ich dachte, Zeit habe ich ja.
Was will ich anderes?
Es ist ...
Die Idee ist gut.
Mal schauen,
was nachher die Leute sagen.
Christoph
will den ehemaligen Strassenarbeiter
möglichst naturgetreu
in Beton giessen.
Zunächst baut er ein kleineres Modell
aus Styropor und Gips,
das er dann auf die Endgrösse
kopieren will -
mithilfe einer von Leonardo da Vinci
erfundenen Methode.
Ich wählte extra ihn aus,
muss ich sagen.
Er ist der Mann aus dem Volk,
der kleine Mann oder ...
Das ist nicht abwertend gemeint.
Sondern er steht ...
für eine Generation.
Für einen Arbeitertyp.
Jemand, der keinen Hintergrund hat,
keine Berühmtheit ist.
Es gibt viel zu wenige Briefkästen.
Der Pöstler
legt die Briefe hier rein,
und der Erste, der dann kommt,
nimmt sie, legt sie hier hoch,
dann sortiert jeder Einzelne
seine eigene Post.
Die Geburt seines Sohnes brachte
viel Licht in das Leben von Daniele.
Fast fünf Jahre lang
lebte er drogenfrei
und kümmerte sich um den Kleinen.
Dann aber platzte der Traum
einer Familie,
und Daniele wurde wieder rückfällig.
Oh, sorry!
* Hupen *
Sein Sohn
wächst bei einer Pflegefamilie auf,
und wenn sich Daniele
an die amtlichen Abmachungen hält,
dann kann er ihn regelmässig sehen.
Aber wenn sich jemand
ein Lied wünschen will,
nach Musikstil oder Thema.
* Einzelne Akkorde *
Entschuldigung.
Jetzt wird es sogar mir peinlich.
Aber wenn du es dann brauchst,
dann brauchst du es.
Jetzt!
Das ist der Blues-Groove und
für Passanten als Gedächtnisstütze:
Ich spiele gerne für euch.
Und wenn ein Passant findet,
dass ich es gut mache ...
Gebt doch eine kleine Spende.
Das würde mich echt freuen.
# Ich bin so und sowieso
und nur e so i mine villne,
# i mine villne ...
# En Tegscht ufschribe,
das isch für mich ...
# Hm ... es schwierigs Ding.
Es geht ja nur um 20, 50 Rp.
oder 1 Fr.
Warum haben alle Mühe zuzugeben,
dass es ihnen gefallen hat?
Nein, ehrlich, ich frage mich.
Echt.
Vielen Dank.
"Kirche, wohin?"
Pete macht sich Sorgen um Daniele:
Seine Post
ist schon wieder liegen geblieben.
Es hat schon wieder
einen Abholschein von Daniele.
Er holt nichts ab,
aber es kommen immer ...
... Bussen vom Busfahren,
und ähm ... ja.
Er nimmt die Sachen nicht entgegen.
Die Situation in der 58
entwickelt sich langsam aber sicher
zu einem echten Problem.
Einige Mieter haben sich beschwert,
dass in der Waschküche
Drogensüchtige übernachten.
Das ist die Haustür.
Daniele hat wie immer
seine Schlüssel verloren.
Darum machte er die Scheibe kaputt.
So konnte er reinfassen
und die Tür von innen öffnen.
Ich drehte es, damit die
kaputte Scheibe hier oben ist.
Das muss ich reparieren lassen.
Aber da gingen so viele Leute
ein und aus, Tag und Nacht -
so etwas spricht sich ja
schnell herum,
dass man hier ein und aus kann.
* Melancholische Bassklänge *
Während Christoph
den Körper von Heinz
mit Gips und Beton neu erschafft,
wird Heinz mit seiner eigenen
Vergänglichkeit konfrontiert.
Sali, Heinz.
So, wie geht's?
Ist es besser? Leicht?
Konntest du schon aufstehen?
- Ja, ja.
Das musst du jeden Tag
zwischendurch machen.
Jeden Tag.
- Jeden Tag. Ja.
Es ist eine Hüftoperation.
Ach, gut, ja.
Ich konnte nicht mehr gehen.
Verdammt,
jeder Schritt hat geschmerzt.
Die Ärztin sagte,
das müsse sofort raus.
Es kommt schon so, wie es muss.
* Melancholische Bassklänge *
Vor Kurzem hat Daniele in der 58
einen Feuerwehreinsatz verursacht.
Wahrscheinlich
eine vergessen gegangene Zigarette.
Pete hat keine andere Wahl:
Daniele verliert seine Wohnung.
Alles Elektrozeug
müssen wir entsorgen.
Ich habe das Methadon
im Kühlschrank vergessen.
Ja, das ist schon gut.
- Tschüss zusammen.
Ih ... Pfui Teufel.
Das kann man putzen,
das ist kein Problem.
Plättli sind von daher noch dankbar.
Das ist nicht verbrannter Teppich
oder Laminat.
Aber überall ist Blut.
Ja, das sieht hier schön aus.
Also der Hauptgrund
war schon der Brand.
Dort hat man gesehen,
dass es auch für die anderen Mieter
langsam gefährlich wird.
Im Prinzip ist es tragisch -
seine ganze Geschichte.
Ich kann nicht sagen ...
Aber ...
Das Verrückte ist,
dass er einen auf Trab hält.
Ich bin auch jemand,
der seinen Alltag bewältigen
und schauen muss, dass ich überlebe.
Wir sind alle irgendwie am Kämpfen.
* Melancholische Bassklänge *
Ich bin nun schon den ganzen Winter
draussen ohne Wohnung.
D.h., es gibt zum Glück eine Beiz,
in der ich jeden Morgen
meinen Schlafsack deponieren
und abends wieder holen darf.
Zum Schlafen.
Daniele muss seine Schlafplätze
von Nacht zu Nacht wechseln,
um das Risiko einer Strafanzeige
möglichst klein zu halten.
Wenn sie hier putzen,
ist es klitschnass.
Die Leute fixen, rauchen Folien hier
und alles Mögliche.
Acid.
Dadurch habe ich den Platz ...
kennengelernt.
Ich habe ihn nicht selbst gefunden.
Jemand hat ihn mir gezeigt.
Das Problem
sind manchmal diejenigen,
die versuchen,
die Autotüren zu öffnen.
Aber bisher
hat mich noch nie jemand verwechselt
und gemeint,
ich sei einer von denen.
Ja.
Ich bin froh,
dass man mir das ansieht.
* Reifenquietschen *
* Stille *
* Skype-Wählvorgang *
Hallo?
Hallo, Adnan. Wie geht's dir?
Internetprobleme - auch in Prag,
nicht nur in Syrien.
Vielleicht hat er zu wenig Akku.
Guten Morgen!
Ich habe versucht, mit Angela zu
reden, aber sie schläft wohl noch.
Vielleicht hat sie gefeiert
und ging spät zu Bett.
Die schlechten Zeiten
haben hoffentlich bald ein Ende.
Und wie sieht es eigentlich
mit der Wohnsituation aus?
Ich suche immer noch,
aber es bringt nichts.
Stell dir vor, all diese Formulare!
Es ist so kompliziert.
Hoffentlich gibt es eine Lösung.
Hauptsache, wir sind bald zusammen.
Wenn wir als Familie zusammen sind,
finden wir eine Wohnung.
Die Caritas wird uns helfen.
Trotzdem bin ich immer am Suchen.
Es ist ganz schlimm, Adnan.
Ich suche seit acht Monaten,
ich weiss nicht wie weiter.
Hier kommt eine Kühlzelle hin.
- Eine Kühltruhe?
Nein,
es ist eine begehbare Kühlzelle.
Sieben verschiedene Friseure
haben im Ladenlokal von Pete
bereits ihr Glück versucht.
Jetzt präsentiert der Somalier
Sabiq Ali seine neue Geschäftsidee.
Das sieht so aus:
Der beginnt hier, bis hierher.
Hast du schon einen Namen
fürs Geschäft?
Ja, es ist eigentlich
selbsterklärend.
Es ist ja ein kleiner Laden.
- Ja.
Wir verkaufen Fleisch,
darum einigten wir uns
auf den Namen Fleischlädeli.
Fleischlädeli?
- Ja, es ist recht einfach.
Und ähm,
man kann es sich auch gut merken.
Es muss natürlich
auch finanziell aufgehen.
Absolut, absolut. Ja, genau.
Aber eben: Wie sagt man?
No risk, no fun.
Ja, ja.
Heinz war auf der Intensivstation.
Bei ihm kam wirklich
vieles zusammen:
die Hüfte, aber dann kam
noch dringender der Hirntumor.
Ich rief oft im Spital an
und fragte nach.
Es hiess jeweils, er sei immer noch
auf der Intensivstation.
Ja, das war ziemlich ...
... dramatisch.
Und ...
Die Ärzte hatten anscheinend
auch nicht erwartet,
dass er wieder aufwacht.
Sie waren überrascht.
Auch seine Frau.
Sie war sehr erfreut.
Er ist dann halt wieder aufgewacht.
Sie haben den Tumor herausgenommen.
Jetzt ist alles draussen.
Das ist gut so.
Einfach so ruhig wie möglich sein
und so tun, als wär nichts.
Das ist das einzig Mögliche.
* Melancholische Bassklänge *
Schon wenige Tage nach der Operation
hat man Heinz
wieder nach Hause entlassen.
Gibt es noch etwas,
das ich dir einkaufen könnte?
Joghurt? Oder hast du alles ...
Ich habe alles da.
- Sag es, ich gehe kurz hin.
Es ist kein Problem,
heute habe ich Zeit.
Gib einfach Bescheid. Brot hast du?
Bist du versorgt?
Ich habe ein Pfünderli Brot.
- Kann ich morgen was bringen?
Ich kann ja das Rote Kreuz anrufen,
die kommen für einen Fünfliber.
Ja, mach das.
- Das bringt's doch nicht.
Wieso nicht?
- Ach.
Dafür gibt es das ja.
Die haben ja extra einen Dienst
für genau solche Fälle.
Du musst sagen.
Wenn du nicht willst ...
Ich dachte, ich könnte morgen
nachschauen, wie es dir geht.
Ich rufe vorher an.
- Egal, mach, was du willst!
Ah, der verdammte Satans-Cheib!
Es nimmt kein Ende.
Ich komme nie an den Punkt,
an dem ich abschliessen kann.
Es ist ein Riesenaufwand.
Die Arme stimmen noch nicht,
die Hände greifen die Banklatten
noch nicht richtig.
Der Faltenwurf bei den Hosen
stimmt auch noch nicht.
Auch die Schuhe sind noch nicht gut.
Die Brustpartie ist noch nicht gut.
Der Kopf auch nicht.
Die Haare nicht und die Ohren
sind auch noch nicht gut.
Es gibt überall noch Dinge,
die besser sein müssten,
bei denen ich noch unzufrieden bin.
Ich muss einen Punkt finden,
an dem ich sagen kann:
"Jetzt ist gut." Ja.
Heinz hat inzwischen einen Platz
in einem Pflegeheim auf
der Sonnenseite der Stadt gefunden.
An seine Auferstehung auf dem Kreisel
glaubt er nicht mehr.
Er ist ein Perfektionist.
Er will es einfach ...
... richtig machen,
wenn er etwas macht.
Nicht wahr?
Ich hätte längst aufgegeben.
Die haben so schöne Balkone
an der Sonne,
sitzen aber nicht draussen.
Das ist eine Sünde und schade.
Angela ist mit dem Auto von Damaskus
zur libanesischen Grenze gefahren.
Wir haben ihr ein Auto
mit einem Fahrer organisiert.
Stundenlang wartete ich
auf ihren Anruf.
Ich wollte wissen,
ob sie das Land verlassen konnte,
aber sie ging nicht ans Telefon.
Als ich sie endlich erreichte,
sagte sie mir,
sie müsse nach Damaskus zurück.
Die Grenzbeamten haben ihr verboten,
zu ihrer Familie zu gehen.
Jetzt müssen wir schauen, ob es
für sie einen anderen Weg gibt,
Syrien zu verlassen.
* Gedämpfte Bluesmusik *
Ich denke an mein Kind. Was denkst
du, ist mein grösster Wunsch?
Ich denke nicht an die Musik,
das Kind ist wichtiger.
Darum war ich in den ersten
zwei Jahren ein guter Vater.
Wenn ich die Gitarre
in die Hand nahm,
protestierte der Bub.
"Papi, spiel nicht mit der Gitarre,
spiel mit mir!"
Dann ... Was habe ich gedacht?
"Ja, du hast recht."
Er liebt mich abgöttisch,
er vergöttert mich.
Ich bin für ihn noch wichtiger
als er für mich. Fast.
Hm.
Das ist recht hoch.
Kommst du so rüber?
Soll ich umkehren?
So geht es, oder?
Ich muss noch kurz halten.
Dann öffnen wir hier drüben die Tür.
Uh!
Einen kleinen hast du auch?
- Ich machte auch einen kleinen.
Und den grossen.
Ich sagte doch, den Bauch
hättest du weglassen können.
Er wird noch etwas geschliffen.
Im Moment
kommt schon noch etwas weg.
Bis jetzt
ist er noch nicht umgekippt.
Er stand auch noch nicht draussen.
* Melancholische Bassklänge *
Nach langen Verhandlungen
durfte Amals Mann von Prag aus
in die Schweiz einreisen.
Die Baselstrasse
hat jetzt zumindest die Eltern
dieser syrischen Familie vereint.
Dishwasher.
Okay.
- Dishwasher.
Cupboards for ...
for putting your things.
* Antreibende Bassmusik *
Woher nimmst du deine Songthemen?
Themen?
- Ja.
Aus dem Leben.
# Am Obe chömed ...
# ... d'Schwigereltere uf Bsuech.
# Jetzt sitzed mer no dune,
no nöd mal öppis gässe.
# Chum gib der jetzt ändlich
emal en Ruck.
# Es isch nöd so,
# wie's jetzt villicht tönt.
Eines Tages dann in der
Abenddämmerung geschieht das,
womit fast keiner mehr gerechnet hat:
Am Kreisel steht alles bereit
für das langersehnte Wunder.
Die Rue de Blamage
bekommt ihr neues Wahrzeichen.
# ... won ich han gha.
# Mer chan nöd immer
de Grund vor Auge ha,
# wo eim motiviert.
# Wo eim motiviert.
Das ist mal was anderes.
# Mach d'Auge uf!
# Wer fragt, was du wetsch?
# Aber es isch nöd
# alles nume schwarz-wiss.
# Ich han en Ufgab.
# Das isch die Bescht, wo's git.
# Die isch würklich dankbar.
# Da chunt so vill zrugg.
SWISS TXT / UT-Redaktion Zürich
Sabine Näpflin - 2017